we knew that that voting had started now
we have the final votes 55 are in favor
of impeaching at President Rousseff so
she will not be going back to her office
today there has been a majority of
Brazilian senators saying that they are
backing impeachment that vote has now
been placed they just needed a simple
majority of 41 senators we have 55
senators actually saying that they well
that they voted for the ruse of
impeachment this of course paves the way
for the Riffe president mr. temer to
take power it seems Alex were also we
know that of course now they have to
bring a letter to Madame Rousseff to
inform her of the fact and then she will
give a speech a little bit later on how
do you manage the Brazilian economy
because away from the corruption away
from the scandal you need some I guess
economic reforms and this is what the
market is believing that the next person
can't botch it more than President
Rousseff yeah Rousseff has no
credibility nor does her regime right
now so it's I guess the good news is we
start with expectations that there's
going to be a much more responsible kind
of leadership on the fiscal side the the
issue though is Brazil has a deep
economic recession and you can't just
turn the dial on that quickly the hope
is that it's kind of around 17 that
central bank will have room to start
cutting rates given that we should see
kind of an improving overall story but I
think the most important step has
already just been taken and what is
interesting here Alex with in Brazil and
it's something I guess we've studied for
a bit our brendan really really quite
good on this and John freyr is this vice
president is basically more of the same
if President Rousseff and then there's
an acting president really within the
scandals the acting president is from
the same cloth isn't he yeah actually
time it's a very good point some of his
colleagues are in fact I think on her
investigation but the key individual who
as far as i understand it has no kind of
questions or clouds around him is the
former central bank governor who is
expected to be a finance minister
Michael McKee with us is all Mike you've
been a student of this for many many
months there's no surprise in this
announcement that
ms rousseff pushed aside but it just
show the turmoil i saw in twitter
yesterday some brazilian athlete saying
don't come to Rio for the Olympics it is
a nation in economic yesterday the the
Harvard Medical School published an
article suggesting that the Olympics be
canceled in Brazil obviously getting rid
of Dilma Rousseff isn't going to solve
Brazil's problems that may bring a
little relief to the markets in the
short run but the country still has
enormous economic difficulties ahead and
with a Senate and legislature and a new
president who are also tainted it's
going to be very hard to get them out of
the